[Music]
I'm sitting here with one of my favorite
comedians and and a good friend of mine
Chris D'Elia
thanks have you be here favorite host
really you had Chris D'Elia white male
black comrade your dad direct yeah yeah
I try and keep my parents as far as well
yeah most people do I feel like I don't
know man like he he's a director and I
will like yeah he's not just like a
carpenter and I was like will you direct
my sabbatical Chris this is really not
appropriate yeah and then he's great at
it and he gets there cuz I when I
started I don't want people to know that
my dad was a director it's like changing
your name yeah like Paul Garfunkel right
I should have picked a bigger Nicolas
Cage Sami Bieber Sam Justin Bieber is
unknown some he's very good at the flute
you you Biebs the Biebs yeah is a fan of
yours yeah he enjoys your comedy yeah I
enjoy your comedy very much
it's weird that I have something in
common with Justin Bieber I almost call
him Jason Bieber cuz who that is yeah
that's his son who changed the wrong
name oh I don't know no I'm Justin
Bieber son I'm gonna change my name to
Jason Bieber cousin just like months
later he just goes oh it keeps cutting
wider and wider until you just see the
world in you does Bieber just go you
know they'll call ahead of time and
they'll clear the upstairs thing then he
asked me to bring him on stage he was
like yeah when you're done with your
site which I thought was cool because
he's like you don't want to like make it
all about him yeah never you're done
bringing out sages just saying we just
like make fun of me like what I'm
wearing like look at this what am i
doing yeah sounds like alright problem
yeah you're not like him you're not Jeff
Ross no no no I one of the I love making
fun of people like and I love being made
fun of but like my friends yeah I agree
it's like I doing yeah like it's an art
like let here you go well I mean do I
really have to it looks like I stepped
in the music
The Lion King that is good actually
handsome how about though that I never
want that pattern this close to my
privates
[Music]